c'est la règle du jeu pas le visage pâle
et cheveux pas d'odeur puisqu'ils ont
même parfois et pas les mêmes ça va être
difficile
j'ai vu le premier candidat alduy au mal
est ce que nous souhaitons fallait il a
tapé très mieux vous pouvez les
dernières vous autorisons toucher
vraiment parfaite si la chose est
dispensée par la ville
[Musique]
j'ai pas beaucoup à offrir à leur
cherchons bouton repères notre deuxième
[Musique]
ses biceps
je rappelle que vous n'aurez le droit de
toucher directement vers le bas
pétitions sait pas ce qu'il fait
[Musique]
vim
moody's reconnaît que ça pousse je vous
laisse un temps à la fiche de tout ça se
vide à ses soldats au dessus vous savez
au moins une école est en train de vie